[Musique]
Je vous salue Marie pleine de grâce oh
Marie conçu sans péché pardonnez-moi mon
père parce que j'ai péché je t'écoute je
viens d'arriver dans le couvent en
qualité d'enseignante et je ne sais pas
si je suis prête quand vous avez écrit
votretoi quoi non rien j'ai des doutes
toi regarde pas la fille
sainteère grâ tu as douté de ce que le
ciel t'a
offert tu es venu dans ce couvent pour
une raison bien précise on doit surtout
pas prendre ses dessins si j' é votre
prénom vous êtes
[Musique]
maudite ne bougez
pas surtout vous retournez
[Musique]
pas
et et si finalement je n'avais vu que ce
que je voulais voir je te comprends ma
fille tu verras tout se passera
[Musique]
bien